bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir une grande figure de la médecine
d'urgence bonsoir Raphaël piti et merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir ça
fait des années que vous formez les
médecins sur les zones de guerre on va
évidemment évoquer avec vous la
situation humanitaire à Gaza où l'aide
arrive mais bien trop lentement vous
êtes actuellement sur liste d'attente
pour vous rendre dans l'enclave
palestinienne on en parle tous les deux
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
notre grand débat ce soir quel bilan
tiré de la visite d'Emmanuel Macron en
Israël et dans les Territoires
palestiniens le chef de l'État a
rencontré Benyamin netaniaou à Jérusalem
et Mahmoud Abbas à ramala il propose une
coalition internationale contre le Hamas
mais sa priorité c'est la libération des
neuf otages franco-israéliens on fera le
point dans le détail avec l'un des
membres d'une famille kidnappée par les
terroristes enfin nos affranchis ce soir
les infos échos de Fanny guinochet le
regard sur l'Europe de Richard Bernier
et puis Bourbon Express raconté ce soir
par Stéphanie des piierres voilà pour le
menu on y va Raphael petit ça vous
regarde ça commence tout de
[Musique]
suite c'est un voyage à auisque tant la
guerre entre le ramas et Israël agite la
France Emmanuel Macron est donc dans
l'État hébreu et en 6 Jordanie ce soir
il a rencontré Benjamin netanahou et
marbouabas le chef de l'État au côté des
familles de français ou francoisraélien
tués disparu ou retenu en otage à Gaza
qui s'est aussi posé en médiateur avec
des propositions concrètes mais la
France a-t-elle vraiment les moyens de
peser dans la région bonsoir Pierre
Alexandre anglad bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes député renaissance des
Français établis dans le bénéuxe
Belgique Luxembourg Pays-Bas vous êtes
président de la commission des affaires
européennes ici à laass Assemblée
nationale bonsoir nicolascré bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste à RMC grand
reporter et vous venez de passer de
semaines en Israël notamment dans le sud
du pays décimé par les attaques
terroristes du ramas bonsoir Vincent
Vincent hugu visage familier dans cette
émission grand reporter également prof
àciencepo vous aussi vous avez couvert
pendant des années la région notamment
pour L'Express enfin bonsoir ange je
suis ravi de vous accueillir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes membre de la
famille Calderon otage du ramas à Gaza
ASI que de la famille d'ne tué par les
terroristes dans le kibutz nirose dans
le sud du pays on va y revenir tout à
l'heure dans le détail Raphaël piti
n'hésitez pas à intervenir dans ce débat
bien sûr quand vous le souhaitez on va
d'abord revenir sur cette visite
présidentielle qu'a-t-il dit le chef de
l'État envoie cela avec Stéphane
blakovski dans son chrono tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
Miriam bonsoir messieurs alors visite
attendue du président de la rép donc
aujourd'hui voilà d'Israël la première
raison c'était pour bien sûr témoigner
son soutien aux Israéliens après
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas son
soutien mais aussi sa solidarité puisque
la France elle aussi est régulièrement
victime d'attaque terroristes et surtout
des Français des compatriotes ont été
tués pendant cette attaque du Hamas on
écoute le président nos deux pays sont
liés par le même
deuil 30 ressortisant français ont été
assassinés par le Hamas et c'est pour
mon pays l'attaque terroriste la plus
meurtrière subit depuis 2016 c'est une
page noire de notre propre histoire
alors dès son arrivée avant même les
rencontres officielles vous allez voir
que le Président vous le savez sans
doute d'ailleurs a rencontré les
familles des victimes françaises des
personnes tuées ou d'autres dont on
imagine qui peuvent être détenu par le
Hamas en expliquant que sa priorité
était bien sûr d'obtenir leur libération
mais sa visite avait aussi un caractère
diplomatique sauf que Ben 17 jours après
le début du conflit pas le premier à
prendre ce genre d'initiative on a
beaucoup parlé de la la visite de Joe
Biden la semaine dernière il y avait
aussi la visite de Richi sunac qui est
le premier ministre britannique alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait la semaine
dernière ben le matin il a rencontré
netanahou en rappelant que Israël avait
le droit de se défendre mais en
respectant le droit et ensuite
l'après-midi et bien il a rencontré
mmoud Abbas en parlant d'une solution à
deux états donc un peu comme ce qu'a
fait Macron aujourd'hui et qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait le lendemain Richi sunak et
bien il a profité de sa présence pour
rencontrer le président égyptien ou le
prince Salman donc rencontrer des chefs
d'État arabes ce que fera ou ce que
devrait faire sans doute Emmanuel Macron
demain donc rien de très original pour
ceux qui sont attachés à la voix
singulière de la France donc conct
international il y a quand même une
proposition inédite du du président
français aujourd'hui il propose donc de
combattre les terrorises du Hamas avec
des moyens qui sont aujourd'hui utilisé
pour combattre daesh on écoute c'est
pourquoi la France est prête à ce que la
coalition internationale contre daesh
dans le cadre de laquelle nous sommes
engagés pour notre opération en Irak et
en Syrie puisse lutter aussi contre le
Hamas alors la coalition à laquelle fait
référence le président elle a été créée
en 2014 pour donc lutter contre daesh
elle roupe 80 pays l'OTAN l'Union
européenne mais aussi des pays arabes
Arabie Saoudite Qatar et aujourd'hui
encore bien l'OP la France participe à
cette opération ça s'appelle l'opération
Chamal donc ça sont les les cartes qui
sont disponibles sur le site du
ministère de la Défense on voit des
bases françaises et puis il y a 600
soldats qui sont engagés toujours pour
empêcher la réurgence de daesh avecz des
avions et si une frégate alors reste à
savoir si d'autres pays se sentent de
rejoindre la France dans cette coalition
la France n'est pas non plus isolée on a
vu que la semaine dernière les chefs
d'État occidentaux s'étaient parlé à
l'OTAN donc j'imagine qu'il y a un
minimum de concertation entre eux cela
dit si la France soutient Israël dans
son combat contre le Hamas le président
aussi dit que pour vivre en paix ce qui
sont doute est l'objectif d'Israël et
bien fallait envisager une solution
politique au conflit en acceptant la
création d'un État palestinien en écoute
la sécurité d'Israël ne peut-être
durable sans une relance décisive du
processus politique avec les
Palestiniens nous l'avons aussi
longuement évoqué voici donc pour le
résumé des premières heures de la visite
du président il a rencontré le
présidentenas cet après-midi en disant
que le Hamas ce n'était pas les
Palestiniens et que les Palestiniens ne
se résumai pas Hamas mais je laisse les
experts débattre merci beaucoup Stéphane
Pierre Alexandre anglad il était attendu
il arrive après d'autres
d'autres Européens sur place on est dans
le symbole avant tout ou vous y voyez
une une véritable portée politique à
cette visite non est pas que dans le
symbole il y a une dimension symbolique
qui est évidente et qui est nécessaire
parce que Israël a vécu les attaques
terroristes les plus brutales de son
histoire et que ça fait évidemment écho
à ce qui a pu se passer en France à
travers les différents attentats
terroristes que nous avons vécu ces
dernières années mais je crois que le
moment de
solidarité avec le peuple israélien
était absolument nécessaire et que la
dimension symbolique est évid mais qu'il
y a aussi une portée politique et cette
portée politique elle s'exprime aussi à
travers cette idée de coalition
internationale pour lutter contre le
terrorisme sur le modèle de ce qui est
fait contre daesh avec une quarantaine
de pays concrètement ça change quoi et
et on est dans quel horizon de temps là
c'est pour l'avenir ou c'est pour tout
de suite je saurais pas vous dire les
les détails techniques puisqu'ils ont
été annoncés mais à l'instant mais ce
qui est évident c'est que la la
coalition qui est aujourd'hui en action
au ProcheOrient en Syrie en Irak contre
DA
différentes formes j'ai vu qu'il avait
pu avoir une forme de polémique qui
avait pu commencer à s'installer cet
après-midi notamment à travers la voix
des insoumis Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
accusait le président de la République
de vouloir envoyer des troupes
françaises bombarder Gaza ou peut-être
intervenir au sol je rappelle que la
coalition internationale qui agit contre
daesh en Irak et en Syrie elle prend
différentes formes c'est la formation
des troupes sur place ça peut être du
renseignement militaire ça peut être la
lutte contre le financement du
terrorisme il s'agit de regarder ce qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui et ce qui
pourrait éventuellement être dupliqué
dans la lutte contre le Hamas qui menace
la stabilité de la région puisque nous
voyons que les attaques terroristes
emporte un certain nombre de de
conséquences et puis de faire en sorte
que la légitime défense qui est celle
d'Israël n'emporte pas plus de
conséquences contre les populations
civiles que celles que nous connaissons
déjà aujourd'hui Vincent HUG il y a du
symbole et puis il y a cette proposition
dont on n'arrive pas encore bien à
cerner les contours très concrets lutter
en commun contre le ramasse avec avec
quel moyen et est-ce que comme le
suggérait Stéphane blakovski tout ça est
concerté pensé ou ou un peu personnel
très franchement je trouve ce concept
baroque l'analogie entre le Hamas et
daesh et
bancal je vois des écueils d'abord
opérationnels la conflictualité d'une
nature totalement différente pour avoir
couvert une partie de la reconquête de
Mossou qui était l'un des quartiers
généraux de ce califat islamique
transnational iraco-syrien en partie
fantasmé en 2017 j'ai pour avoir aussi
pas mal sillné et déambulé dans les
ruelles de de Gaza je ne vois vraiment
pas comment on peut comparer les deux
terrains ensuite vous avez un écueil
politique Israël n'en a aucune envie
Israël ne délègue à personne la gestion
de sa sécurité si calamiteuse soit-elle
en l'occurrence sinon en accord avec le
Parin américain et puis il y a aussi
pardonnez-moi mais un écueil historique
il y a d'autres coalition internationale
qui ont laissé des traces indélébiles et
plutôt détestables dans les opinions
arabes Irak 2003 Libye 2011 Afghanistan
ensuite puis en dernier dernier point
quand même le format de cette coalition
les coalitions sont censées être en
partie je dirais arabiser en tout cas
embarquer des pays arabes vous imaginez
vous le le Qatar ou l'Égypte allait
contribuer au bombardement de de du
Hamas et en plus dernier point j'ai j'ai
mesuré à travers quelques échanges que
ça avait plongé dans une certaine
perplexité y compris des gens au kedorsé
voir à l'Élysée donc très franchement je
je suis assez perplexe par rapport à
cette initiative et vous Nicolas pocarré
le voyage de Joe Biden on peut dire
qu'il a ouvert la porte de Rafa le point
de passage par le sud via l'Égypte des
premiers convois humanitaires petite
ouverture on en parlera d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure avec Raphaël piti mais au
moins on a vu concrètement à quoi il
avait servi à quoi a servi ce ce voyage
cette première étape dans l'État hébreux
et et ramala aujourd'hui moi je crois
que c'est c'est euh on est dans le
symbole on est dans le symbole tout le
le chancelier allemand y est allé le
Premier ministre britannique y est allé
la présidente de la Commission
européenne y est allé il fallait que
qu'Emmanuel Macron y aille pour pour ce
qu'il a fait et ce qu'il a dit
c'est-à-dire d'abord afficher une
solidarité avec un peuple qui vient de
subir un crime barbare euh d'autre part
dire deux mots effectivement sur le le
aux Israéliens que que on qu'on n pas
non plus dans le soutien inconditionnel
comm m'avait dit orurcela van Lyan on
est on est dans le soutien mais en leur
disant attention il y a quand même des
règles et on est préoccupé par ce qui
arrive euh au au civil à Gaza il fallait
le dire et puis et puis ce voyage à
ramala qui qu'il est le premier à faire
à part le le ministre des Affaires
étrangères je crois des des Pays-Bas
donc c'est aussi important parce que la
France longtemps a eu une politique
arabe la France longtemps a été
considérée comme un pays qui qui savait
se situer à mchemin entre les
belligérant alors que les États-Unis eux
étaient toujours éternellement s la
France longtemps a eu elle n'a plus le
poids C politique AR je pense que cette
politique
arabe je dirais qu'elle a duré jusqu'au
jour où shirac avait dit est-ce que vous
voulez que je retourne à mon avion
c'était mis en colère dans les Ruel de
de la vieille mais sur le poid politique
sur l'influence de notre pays non non
non il faut non je crois qu'on en a plus
c'est pour ça que je disais que c'était
important d'aller faire tout ça d'aller
dire aux Israéliens avec vous c'était
important je fais une parenthèse mais
c'était aussi important pour nous
c'était aussi important pour pour les
Français de voir que leur président et
solidaire des Israéliens mais c'est
aussi parler au Palestiniens se rendre à
ramala et dire de de mot ce qui se passe
à Gaza c'est on est quand même un pays
très déchiré en ce moment et donc tout
ça est important mais maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça aura comme conséquence
rien rien on peut pas imaginer c'est pas
c'est pas en serrant la main de
marboutabas ce soir à ramala qu'on va
faire avancer un tout petit peu les
choses c'est pas en disant que ce serait
bien d'avoir une trêve humanitaire qu'on
fait avancer les choses c'est on on est
dans le symbole mais le symbole
important je pas que sil fallait pas y
aller je dis juste que il y aura sans
doute aucune conséquence à soy ange on
va venir dans le détail sur ou
oui vousz de de de vous trouver un petit
peu pessimiste euh l'optimisme est par
nature inscrit chez nous peuple juif
parce qu'on y est obligé donc
premièrement le président Macron a
longuement parlé des otages français et
des victimes françaises et il a dit que
c'était un des pires attentats que la
France elle-même est subi donc là c'est
on est déjà bien au-delà du simple
symbole d'autre part on on le critique
beaucoup pour sa visite tardive par
rapport aux autres euh vous savez dans
les armées
l'arrièregarde c'est parfois plus
important que l'avant-garde et le fait
qu'il veuille rencontrer tout le monde
et que sa priorité sa première rencontre
a été avec ma propre famille les images
qui ont été diffusées ce matin montrer
l'échange de poignet qu'il avait avec
mes petites cousines à galit Dan et
hadas
Calderon c'est au-delà du symbole je
m'excuse d'être peut-être trop optimiste
et il leur a dit et Adas lui en est très
reconnaissante elle dit je suis Fiè
d'être française et j'ai confiance
Macron je vous propose qu'on parle parce
que cette crise des otages 200 s otages
elle traumatise tout le monde chacun
d'entre nous on va essayer de comprendre
et rentrer dans le dans le détail sur
sur les négociations sur ce qu'on peut
attendre de de la France c'est sans
doute le terrain sur lequel notre pays
peut espérer avancer sur les 200 otages
détenus par le ramas neuf sont français
ou franco-israéliens et la pression
monte pas seulement en Israël dans bon
nombre de capitales du du monde entier
regardez ce sujet il est signé mait
frréont il s'appelle Amira Tomer Ariel
tous enlevés par le Hamas le 7 octobre
dernier dans cette vidéo diffusée sur
Internet les photos défil plus de 200
visages des jeunes hommes des jeunes
femmes et des enfants de 22 nationalités
différentes parmi eux au moins une
Française peut-être
car Paris est son nouvelle de H de ses
ressortissants en visite en Israël
Emmanuel Macron a fait de la question
des otages sa
priorité le prier obtif nous
devu tion les es sans
aucunetinction car c'est un crime
horrible que de jouer avec ses
vies enfant adul tout le monde civil et
militair dans le monde entier à Paris
New York Madrid des manifestations pour
réclamer leur libération des bougies des
ta VI
pour ce que représent 200 personnes
disparues qui ont été retiré à leur
famille de façon sauvage donc cette
table elle symbolise les 200 personnes
qui aurait dû être avec nous ce soir en
3 jours la pression diplomatique
mondiale avec comme acteur principaux
les États-Unis et le Qatar a permis à
quatre otages de retrouver la liberté
deux Américaines une mère et sa fille
pour raisons humanitaires et hier deux
israéliennes octogénèes l'une d'elles
témoigne on était allongé sur des
matelas il prenait vraiment soin de
notre hygiène pour qu'on ne tombe pas
malade un médecin venait tous les de ou
3 jours pour voir comment on allait et
l'infirmier s'occupait de nous donner
des
médicaments dans son récit cet otage
explique avoir marché des
kilomètres un système géant de tunnel
comme des toiles d'araignée selon les
responsables israéliens de nombre ages
pour être détenu dans ce dédal de tunnel
sous
Gaza alors je reviens vers vous ange
pour bien comprendre euh ce que traverse
votre votre famille en Israël vous êtes
le cousin d'adas Calderon et galit d'
elles sont sœurs Adas et galit et leur
mère et leurs enfants étaient au kibut
nirose le jour des massacres du 7
octobre certains sont morts d'autres
sont aotage du ramas racontez-nous
précisément ce que vit votre famille
peut-être commençons
par par les les personnes qui ont été
tuées par carmellaa et noya ça s
malheureusement passé en plusieurs
épisodes nous avons dans un premier
temps appris que il y avait C
membre de notre famille qui habitait
donc le kibou nirose qui était porté
disparu il faut savoir que le kibout
nirose un sur le plan géographique est
au plus près de Gaza et donc les
commandos de terroristes avaient des
ordres différents suivant les cibles ce
quiibout cétant le plus proche de la
frontière avec Gaza visiblement le mot
d'ordre était fait un maximum d'otage
kidnapper le maximum de personnes que
vous pouvez c'était à 3 km une encablure
de mobylette donc
la la majorité des otages actuellement
proviennent d'après les sources de ceux
qui boutent cela duukibout n rose euh
donc dans un premier temps nous avons
appris que CQ était porté disparu
et nous pensions nous espérions nous
avons eu ce message terrible de notre
grand cousin qui vit là-bas ISAI qui
nous disait heureusement nous avons vu
RS qui est un petit garçon de 12 ans sur
une vidéo de propagande du ramas nous
sommes contents il est vivant et nous
avons faut comprendre ça plusieurs fois
ce message pour comprendre la Bonne
Nouvelle d'avoir été kidnappé par le RAM
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle il n'est que kidnappé et puis
mardi soir mardi soir ce qu'on voit là
une c'est une nuit funeste voilà mardi
soir nous avons appris que un drone
avait survolé maintenant l'espèce de
nomans Land qu'il y a entre Gaza et
l'armée qui est en position d'attaque et
ce drone avait vu que dans cette partie
des corps plusieurs corps étaient là
étendus il a été envoyé un commandoau
spécial de nuit pour récupérer les corps
et nous avons appris cette nuit-là que
Carmel là 80 ans la grand-mère de Noa
qui venait passer ses vacances au kibuts
car Noa ne c'était une période de
vacances en Israël à ce moment-là
c'était sous côte euh la fête des
cabanes et donc noya passer les vacances
auprès de sa grand-mère au kibuts et
noya est autiste était autiste et vivait
dans le monde enchanté de Harry Potter
et se prenait pour hermion on a beaucoup
de photos d'elle en costume d'hermieux
la photo a beaucoup circulé de l'auteur
d'Arry Potter donc nous avons appris ce
jourl que les deux malheureusement étai
mortte et qu'il ne nous en restait plus
que trois euh quelques jours après
offert her et ça on va voir aussi offert
le père des deux enfants euh voilà c'est
c'est offert et heres et
SAR donc qui sont ses enfants nous
espérons qu'ils sont ensemble tous les
trois
et pour l'instant nous sommes sans
nouvell et quand nous entendons que le
MAE le korsé n'est pas sûr des chiffres
lui-même nous en tremblons
de ces deux enfants qu'on voit derrière
moi a rencontré on l'a vu ce matin Adas
le chef de l'État français leur a-t-il
donné de l'espoir à notre chef d'État
énormément énormément et Adas je je
transmets ses
propos encore une fois a dit qu'elle
était très fière d'être française que le
président Macron c'était montré très à
l'écoute et qu'il avait dit que sa
priorité était la libération des otages
et il l'a dit vraisemblablement de tous
les otages ce qui n'est pas facile
sachant que en face le Hamas a déjà mis
une espèce d'échelle dans les otages les
gens kidnappés il a dit que
effectivement les binationaux seraient
traités d'une manière différente que les
Israéliens et parmi les Israéliens le
sort réservé aux civils ne serait pas le
même que celui réservé au soldats h donc
pour nous notre famille on s'enfonce
dans le tragique ça voudrait dire que
les deux enfants pourraient être libéré
par les négociations mises en place donc
au-delà du symbole je m'excuse de vous
contrarier possible j'espère et je le
veux de tout mon cœur avec le Qatar avec
l'Égypte euh nous nous sommes prêts à
parler avec le diable s'il le faut sans
pour autant passer de pacte faustien
mais de lui parler nous y sommes prêts
alors on va essayer de comprendre avec
vous ce qui se joue déjà dans la société
israélienne nicoda point carré autour de
ces 200 otages et et qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière ce mot de négociation avec qui
déjà d'après nos confrères du du
Parisien ce soir sachez que le président
français réfléchit à un hommage national
pour les les victimes françaises tuées
en Israël Nicolas Poincaré vous revenez
d'Israël au début on a eu le sentiment
que certes c'était un traumatisme
national mais que la priorité c'était la
riposte et puis chaque so voir des
nouvelles manifestations avec les
visages est-ce qu'aujourd'hui cette
société
traumatisée veut à tout prix la
libération je crois que moi ce que j'ai
senti c'est qu'effectivement les
Israéliens sont traumatisés par ce qui
s'est passé le 7 octobre qui était
tellement énorme qu'ils ont mis
plusieurs jours à réaliser le dimanche
le lundi le mardi le mercredi on
apprenait encore l'ampleur de de de de
ce de ces massacres donc ça c'est une
chose et puis effectivement la crise des
otaches elle est énorme parce que c'est
un pays qui a toujours attaché beaucoup
d' ance à la vie d'un seul otage parfois
même Israël a négocié des mois et des
mois pour des corps de soldats ou des
corps
d'otage ils sont allé jusqu'à échanger
1000 contre un notage soldat Chalit donc
200 c'est inimaginable c'est absolument
inimaginable et c'est c'est la plus
grosse prise d'otage dont j'ai souvenir
depuis que je fais ce métier depuis une
quarantaine d'années j'ai pas souvenir
qu'on a même les che Chen qui ont fait
des trucs terribles et C n'ont pas eu
n'ont pas eu de chibok ouais seul
précédent de même amplitude avec une
différence là ce sont les enfants il y a
un nombre de bébés il y a des bébés qui
sont en otage il y a parmi les les les
Français au moins trois mineurs dont
deux de de la famille d'ange donc
effectivement la société israélienne est
s le choc c'est c'est quelque chose
c'est qui est au-delà de tout ce qui
avait pu se passer auparavant père
Alexandre Anglade sans nous donner
forcément les secrets d'État mais la
France multiplie les coups de fil on
parle du Qatar quel est le rôle de
l'émir du Qatar dans les négociations il
y a eu déjà deux Américaines qui ont été
mère et filles libéré une
franco-américaine une israéloaméricaine
une 100 % américaine et là deux femmes
israéliennes âgées vous imaginez pour
les familles qu'est-ce qui se passe
quelles sont les raisons d'espérer quels
sont les rôles de de qui et notamment du
Qatar dans les négociations je crois
d'abord que Monsieur A a livré ce soir
un témoignage extrêmement émouvant et je
crois que ce que vous avez
décrit chacune et chacun des Françaises
et des Français qui nous écoutent ce
soir peut s'y retrouver parce qu'une
petite fille qui va en vacances chez ses
grands parents nous sommes période de
vacances de la tousin je pense que c'est
le cas de beaucoup de familles
françaises que fait la France on peut'
imaginer le évidemment l'horreur absolue
je crois que le Président de la
République l'a dit depuis le premier
depuis les premières heures de la crise
le dialogue politique a tout de suite
été nourri avec les partenaires de la
région et en particulier évidemment avec
le Qatar qui a un rôle central dans le
dénouement de cette crise et qui a un
lien particulier un lien particulier
avec le Hamas puisque beaucoup de de
chefs du Hamas se trouve aujourd'hui à
DOA que le Qatar entretient des liens
financiers avec cette organisation et
donc et nous savons aussi les liens qui
existent entre la France et le Qatar à
travers d'autres réseaux mais sont pas
pas simplement mais et donc il y a
effectivement le dialogue qui est mené
par le président avec le Qatar mais
aussi avec tous les acteurs de la région
pour faire en sorte que les otages
puissent être libérés le plus rapidement
possible mais nous voyons bien que nous
sommes dans une situation extrêmement
complexe comp tenu du fait que nous ne
savons nous sommes même pas capables de
dire aujourd'hui quel serait le nombre
précis d'otage puisque 30 français ont
perdu la vie dans les attentats neuf
sont portés disparu il y a une
présemption présemptionune partie
d'entre eux est aujourd'hui otage mais
sans certitude Vincent je les
négociations qu'est-ce qu'on en sait
qu'est-ce qui se passe en préambule si
le voyage d'Emmanuel Macron aboutisser
au retour à liberté d'un seul otage so
français franco-israélien ou autre on
pourrait déjà considérer que cet
escapade était utile deuxième remarque
les négociations s'accommode formal de
la publicité ce qui se joue doit se
jouer dans le secret troisème remarque
l'émirat du Qatar a beaucoup à se faire
pardonner expliquez-nous ça écoutez la
matrice idéologique du pouvoir Catari
elle est celle des Frères musulmans
c'est-à-dire elle est commune à la
matrice idéologique du Hamas et
d'ailleurs il n'est pas anodin de
souligner que parmi les pays qui peuvent
peser dans ces négociations qui encore
une fois doivent rester aussi
clandestines que possible pour être
efficace vous avez donc le Qatar et la
Turquie et la Turquie de REP Tayip
Erdogan elle aussi est adossée à la même
idéologie frériste et
donc le levier du Qatar est sans doute
le le plus efficace aujourd'hui
simplement et je termine là-dessus il
faut avoir à l'esprit
que le Hamas s'est constitué et je le
dis sans cynisme aucun à un stock
d'otage dont il veut faire le meilleur
usage opérationnel notamment en gagnant
mais bien sûr il s'agit de gagner du
temps il s'agit d'instiller le doute
dans la pertinence d'une opération
terrestre massive sur le nord de la
bande il s'agit de jouer des tensions
internes à la société israélienne car n
nous faisons pas d'illusion c'est
l'union sacrée et ça c'est toute
l'histoire d'Israël quand vous êtes
devant une un péril existentiel comme
celui-là mais les jours de Benyamin
netanahou en tant que Premier ministre
de l'État d'Israël sont comptés et c'est
aussi l'occasion pour le Hamas de
compliquer la donne de mettre en place
des dispositifs défensifs avec des
tireurs embusqués avec des pièges avec
des mines brouiller les pistes des
tunnels dont pourtant les services
israliens connaissent à peu près la
cartographie donc il faut vraiment avoir
à l'esprit que la fraternité entre la la
République islamique d'Iran et et le
Hamas n'est pas tout à fait fortuite
puisqueau fond théran a
théorisé l'usage des des otage pour en
obtenir éventuellement des bénéfices
politiques ou ou stratégiques ange
peut-être une réflexion de votre part je
sais pas si vous l'avez entendu ralad
méchal les chefs du ramas s'expriment
assez peu mais quand il s'expriment il
faut quand même les entendre pour
essayer de comprendre que les Israéliens
arrêtent de bombarder Gaza en substance
et les autres seront libérés comment
quand on est une famille réagit à ça
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est terrible
c'est je te tiens tu me tiens par là les
Israéliens n'ont rien commencé dans
cette histoire ils se sont fait avoir
par par un subserfuge de la part du
Hamas je sais pas si vous en êtes au
courant le Hamas et le Djihad islamique
ne sont pas spécialement amis ils se
livre une lutte intestine dont ils sont
assez spécialistes
et le le ramas a
distillé auprès du chinbê et du Mossad
des informations pour donner service de
renseignement pour donner pour donner
des des gens du dihad islamique
le gouvernement israëlien s dit bon à
part quelques obus de temps en temps ils
sont tranquilles ils vont nous ficher la
paix
euh et ils se sont fait avoir comme ça
ils se sont été endormis comme ça moi je
voudrais quand même rappeler que le
Hamas d'abord est une organisation
reconnue comme terroriste sur le plan
international que sa charte dans sa
charte il est écrit que il vise la
destruction de l'État d'Israël et son
remplacement par un État islamique et je
voulais aussi parce que je suis là aussi
pour ça dire que comme le président
Macron en a parlé je suis ici aussi pour
dire que nous ici en France au même
titre que lui veut faire un hommage
nationale à nos ressortissants en France
nous nous sommes en train de mettre sur
pied une association en collaboration
avec la funvac f VAC dont on trouve les
coordonnées rien qu'en tapant ses
lettres pour
réunir toutes les familles concerné que
ce soit des familles d'otage des
familles de gens décédés et des familles
je le dis souvent sur les antennes où je
passe maintenant des familles de blessés
dont on ne parle pas comme s'il n'y en
avait pas
à croire que il n'y a que des kidnappés
ou des morts et et l'appel est passé ce
soir d'ailleurs il y a même des actions
en justice contre le ramasse et des
plaintes qui sont différentes mais je
voulais les mentionner Raphaël piti la
question des otages elle est aussi une
donnée centrale dans la question de
l'humanitaire les Israéliens
conditionnent l'aide humanitaire à la
libération des otages surtout des femmes
des enfants et des personnes âgées ne
mettant pas les les hommes donc ce qu'il
demande immédiatement c'est la
libération de de ces personneslà et ils
ont raison de le faire et ils ont raison
de le faire ils ont raison de le faire
bien évidemment mais vraiment je suis
très profondément touché par le drame
qu'a vécu Israël très profondément et et
j'en suis très touché mais nous
nassistons depuis une dizaines d'années
qu'à une montée de la violence une
violence qui est indiscriminée vis-à-vis
des populations on peut rappeler le
massacre de boucha parler l'armée russe
par exemple près de Kiev les massacres
de daesh ou des rebelles ou de Assad en
Syrie on il y a constamment les
populations innocentes sont prises au
piège de ces de ces causes idéologiques
ou de ses causes géostratégiques et
cetera c'est terrible c'est qui arrive à
Israël mais ce qui arrive en même temps
la population palestinienne qui est tout
aussi innocente que la population
israélienne ce qui arrive on va en
parler tout à l'heure et est terrible en
ce moment elle est terrible ilû bien sûr
mais vous savez tout tous c kibuts étai
des kibuts de gauche le kibuts de NIR
rose était un kibuts à chemer à Saï le
leitant de la paix voilà militant de la
paix ils avaient des amis Gazaoui ils
avaient des amis Gazaoui Reny levvi qui
était qui était un des membres
fondateurs et dirigeants du kibuts Berry
où se passait la il y a une interview
terrible de lui des archives qui est
passé il y a quelques jours sur fort où
il racontait que il y a quelques années
il y avait des travailleurs Gazaoui au
au kibou et que suite au différents
événements ces travailleurs ne venaient
plus c'était des Thaïlandais qu'ils
avaient et bien à la à la à la fin du
mois tous les mois il continuaient de
les payer et de leur envoyer de l'argent
et ces
gens-là quand on évoque tous ces gens-là
on pourrait penser que le Hamas mon Dieu
ah les pauvres il se sont trompés de
cible mais pas du tout keneni le ramas
n'aime pas les pacifistes le ramas
n'aime pas la paix le ramas n'aime pas
la vie oui Nicolas PointCarré pour pour
terminer ce débat certains services de
renseignement j'ai pu lire ça expliqu
même que ce n'est pas complètement
certain que le ramas et la main totale
sur les otages c'est possible ça non
alors moi je je partage la vie de de de
Vincent on en sait très peu et si on nen
savait plus ce serait peut-être pas
nécessaire de le dire mais la vérité la
vérité c'est que on on on ne sait rien
on on a eu des toutes premières bribes
d'information avec cette age octogéire
qui est sorti ce matin qui a été la
première à parler hein et qui a dit
qu'elle avait été à un moment rassemblé
dans un groupe qui était jusqu'à 25
otages je crois donc là on avait une
information c'est c'est la femme d'un
d'un des pacifistes les plus actifs de
du kibou nirose qui disait qu'elle avait
été plutôt ça à part ça les les deux
otages américanoisraéliennes qui sont
sortis le premier jour n'ont pas pris la
parole publiquement donc c'est pas dans
ques conditions é est-ce que vous pensez
que la pression des Israéliens parce qu'
auaujourd'hui il y a des familles qui
campent littéralement devant le siège de
tsal de l'armée de l'État maajor à Tel
Aviv est-ce que ça peut avoir un effet
la question des otages sur la riposte
notamment thèse sur l'éventuelle retenue
sur la manière dont Israël va se
défendre dans les prochains jours ou pas
non je crois que les décisions sont sont
prises he les décisions sont prises
israël veut veut rentrer dans dans Gaza
et se préparer éventuellement à une
deuxième guerre avec le Liban
la question des otages est dramatique
mais je suis pas sûr qu'elle suffisant à
empêcher ces offensives on va s'arrêter
là je vous remercie infiniment d'être
venu débattre une petite image pour
terminer ce débat sachez qu'en ce moment
même à l'Assemblée nationale nos
confrères de Radio J organiseent un
événement en présence de nombreuses
personnalités vous le voyez des élus des
anciens ministres l'ancien président de
la République François Hollande et je
crois sans me tromper ange dire aussi
que un certain nombre de membres de
famille de otage de de personnes
kidnappées israéliennes
franco-israéliennees par le ramas sont
également présentes merci à vous d'être
venu débattre vous restez avec moi
Raphaël piti dans une dizaine de minutes
les affanchis pour leur parti prix avec
ce soir Fanny guinochek qui va nous dire
pourquoi le gouvernement renonce à
ponctionner les retraites
complémentaires à quoi jour sur la Vand
Len c'est vous qui vous interrogez ce
soir Richard verli dans votre billet
européen et puis dans Bourbon express de
quoi parle-t-on Stéphanie Despierre de
l'article 3 de la future loi immigr sur
la régulation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension très
bien à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va parler on va continuer de
parler de la situation à Gaza avec vous
Raphaël piti vous vous apprêtez donc à
partir dans l'enclave palestinienne pour
aider les urgentistes totalement épuisés
totalement débordé dans les hôpitaux sur
place regardez c'est dans l'invitation
de ma frmont et vous nous en dites plus
juste
après si on vous invite Raphaël piti
c'est pour avoir votre regard
d'humanitaire de médecins de guerre sur
la situation catastrophique de la
population de Gaza sous le feu continue
des bombes israéliennes en attendant une
attaque terrestre il y a des
interventions chirurgicales qui se font
sans anesthésie parce que justement ils
en ont très peu et ils les conservent
essentiellement pour les les patients
les plus graves donc c'est une situation
humanitaire qui est à peine inimaginable
aujourd'hui et qui est véritablement
voulu c'est-à-dire c'est une catastrophe
humanitaire annoncée cette catastrophe
une lueur
d'espoir 3 semaines après l'attaque du
Hamas des camions entrre au contegoutte
depuis plusieurs jours dans l'enclave
palestinienne depuis la frontière avec
l'Égypte les besoins les plus pressents
en ce moment c'est le carburant l'eau la
nourriture les médicaments alors le
carburant pourquoi parce que c'est avec
le carburant qu'on fait qu'on fait de
l'eau qu'on produit de l'eau à à Gaza il
n'y a pas d'eau potable et sur place
dans des hôpitaux en ruine confrontés à
la pénurie de médicaments certains
médecins opèrent et sauvent des vies
avec les moyens du bord sur les réseaux
sociaux ils témoignent de leur quotidien
comme avec ce vinaigre de supermarché
qui leur permet de soigner les patients
faute de mieux les hôpitaux de fortune
sur les terrains de guerre vous
connaissez vous êtes médecin militaire
anesthésiste réanimateur urgentiste et
professeur de méde d'urgence et de
catastrophe vous en avez formé des
médecins dans des simulations de scènes
de guerre comme ici en Moselle ou encore
en Syrie où vous avez effectué près de
20 voyages depuis
2012 dans un lieu tenu secret une
formation à la médecine de combat pour
ces soignants syriens cible du régime
car en première ligne sur le front pour
sauver des vies face à l'urgence vous
êtes dans les starting block pour partir
à Gaza où vous ne vous êtes jamais rendu
dans votre vie alors on a une question
ce soir quelle est votre antise dans
l'attente du
départ réponse Raphael
piti menti c'est c'est de voir ce qui se
passe en ce moment et de ne Pasir pas
pouvoir intervenir nous avons été nous
sommes toutes les ONG et parmi les les
plus grandes bien évidemment Médecins du
Monde médecins Sans Frontière et
d'autres à 4 et cetera sont euh sont
révulsés par ce qui se passe et dans
l'impossibilité de pouvoir agir nous ne
pouvons pas rentrer à l'intérieur de
Gaza nous ne pouvons pas obtenir de de
pause humanitair nous alors il y a cette
c'est qu'on voit cette ouverture petite
ouverture via Rafa autorisé par Israël
depuis 3 jours avec l'envoi d'environ
une vingtaine de convois par jour via le
le poste Sud avec avec l'Égypte à la
frontière qu'est-ce qu'on sait
précisément de l'aide qui parvient euh
au Gazaoui depuis quelques jours je
voudrais juste pour remettre les choses
dans leur à leur juste dimension je vous
en prie tous les jours il arrive 3 plus
de 300 camions pour la zone de Gaza tous
les jours dans la situation normale et
là depuis 15 jours il en est rentré 17 à
peu près voilà euh la telle
disproportion par rapport aux besoins
est énorme est énorme 17 ça n'est rien
une goutte d'eau par rapport au au
véritable au
besoins je ne sais pas si vous voulez
qu'on décrive la situation allez-y bon
c'est important pour comprendre voilà
vous avez 2 million
de personnes qui sont dans la zone de
Gaza qui vivent depuis plus de 15 ans du
fait du blocus dans une situation de
très grande précarité voire de misère
ils sont complètement dépendants de
l'aide humanitaire internationale et qui
justement leur apporte par
l'intermédèire de ces camions leur
apport une part de ce dont ils ont
besoin et là maintenant ils sont otage
véritablement de la situation qui a été
faite par ce massacre en Israël je le
comprends j'ai de la compassion
terriblement mais j'ai une très grande
compassion au même temps pour cette
population qui est innocente et qui
subit tous les jours tous les jours des
bombardements et un siège MSF avec qui
vous étiez on va revenir sur le siège et
le blocus total de l'électricité
notamment qu' a des conséquences
notamment sur les hôpitaux MSF avec qui
vous étiez interrogé chez nos confrères
de quotidien il y a quelques jours
expliquait que le stock d'anesthésian
était épuisé et qu'on faisait des
opérations à Gaza sans anesthésie sans
an est-ce que ça ça a changé ou c'est
toujours le cas non c'est toujours le
cas bien évidemment et c'est même pire
dans la situation parce qu'ils n'ont
pratiquement plus de file j'ai le
dernier message que j'ai d'un des
médecins qui est à Gaza il dit nous
n'avons plus que pour quelques heures le
fouel qui est indispensable pour faire
fonctionner les hôpitaux sur place les
générateurs les les groupes les
générateurs y compris même pour la
dialyse il y a un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont besoin d'être dialysé
pour faire fonctionner ces appareils de
dialyse il faut de l'électricité ils
n'ont plus il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui
sont aussi en insuffisance rénale
terminale qui ont besoin d'être dialysé
comme les adultes pas de pas de de
filtre pas de matériel non plus de pour
pouvoir brancher ces ces ces patients là
et troisièmement il y a s'il y a plus
d'électricité ils sont condamnés à mort
on est dans cette situation on a plus de
4000 personnes qui sontcron a d'ailleurs
demandé à ce que le blocus ne concerne
pas l'électricité dans les hôpitaux on
verra la R qu'il obtient des Israéliens
les médecins sur place vous leur parlez
dans quel état sont oui alors il se
trouve qu'il y a deux personnes un il y
a un médecin qui est français et qui est
actuellement qui était à Gaza qui est
francopestinien et qui est à Gaza qui se
retrouve coincé mais il y a aussi un
francoanglais qui est un professeur de
néphrologie chirurgien qui était parti à
Gaza pour une mission de Greff rénale et
il est coincé à Gaza depuis maintenant 2
semaines bien évidemment nous sommes en
relation avec eux et ils expliquent la
situation ils sont épuisés ils n'ont
plus de matériel ils sont débordés par
le nombre de de de victimes qu'ils ont
qu'ils prennent en charge mais aussi par
la population il y a énormément des
milliers de personnes qui viennent
s'agglutiner autour de des hôpitaux
persuadés que ces hôpitaux ne seront pas
bombardés ce qui n'est pas vrai et et le
fait que la population soit
progressivement évacué on sait qu'on est
à plus d'un million de Gazaoui qui se
sont déplacés vers vers le sud euh on
peut les soigner tout de même
si il manquera des hôpitaux il manque
des hôpitaux mais il manque aussi de
médicaments les pathologies chroniques
ne peuvent pas être pris en charge ce
qui veut dire qu'il y a le pronostic
vital d'un certain nombre de patients
les les insuffisants cardiaques les
insuffisants respiratoires toute cette
pathologie là se retrouve sans sans
moyens sans médicaments vous avez écrit
je crois Emmanuel Macron pour lui faire
des des proposition de solution pour les
ONG médicales sur place avez-vous eu des
réponses qu'est-ce que que vous proposez
je crois la même chose une sorte de
partition en différentes zones comme il
y en avait en Syrie pour pour les
médecins alors c'est exactement ça nous
étions huit association et ONG à avoir
demandé un rendez-vous à l'Élysée que
nous avons eu hier matin et nous avons
chacun exprimé bien évidemment nous
étions d'accord pour dire qu'il fallait
immédiatement mettre en place une une
trêve humanitaire la plus rapide cesser
le feu là de suite immédiat pour prendre
en charge cette population et bien
évidemment chacun développa les
recommandations qu'il pouvait faire pour
ce qui me concerne la recommandation
c'était de dire il se trouve que
l'état-major israélien proposait une
zone sécurisée à canyones dans le sud
dans le sud le long de la mer elle est
relativement étroite cette zone mais il
proposait une zone de sécurité pour les
populations du Nord qui descendit et
cetera elle est mal positionnée bien
évidemment elle est trop loin de la
frontière égyptienne on va peut-être
voir une carte pour voà et nous nous
voudrions que cette zone de sécurité qui
était proposée par les Israéliens
d'accord la zone que vous voulez vous
canones nous nous voudrions que cette
zone descende plus basse à partir de
canyones jusqu'à Rafa d'accord c'est
très clair jusqu'à Rafa de manière moin
près de la mer voilà plus proche de
l'Égypte pour avoir justement ce couloir
humanitaire qui permettra
l'approvisionnement c'est une zone là
qui va permettre justement il y a
plusieurs hôpitaux à assez important
dans cette zone là avec plusieurs il y
en a deux au moins qui ont six à Sep
blocs opératoires on pourrait
éventuellement y faire rentrer d'autres
hôpitaux pour assurer la prise en charge
des patients qui sont nécessaires pour
les évacuer du Nord vers le Sud il
seraiit ravitaillé par le passage de
Rafa bien évidemment et nous on pourrait
obtenir de l'Égypte d'assurer bien
évidemment l'observation de la sécurité
sans demander à l'ONU comme ça s'est
passé pour la zone de Idlib en Syrie
cette zone-là dont il y avait 12 postes
d'observation à l'intérieur de la zone
qui étit turc nous pourrions avoir les
l'Égypte pourrait aussi déployer des
postes d'observation pour assurer la séc
cette demande elle a été relayée par la
France auprès de Benyamin netanah nous
avons en tous les cas fait la
proposition et nous avons dit et et ça
me semble important de le dire que la
singularité de la France par rapport à
nos valeurs qui sont les nôtres des
droits de l'homme et cetera la
singularité de Monsieur Macron ce serait
juste devenir avec un plan humanitaire
voilà j'entends très bien la la volonté
de de détruire le Hamas et Cera ça je
veux bien l'entendre mais ce que
personne ne porte c'est justement
d'apporter un plan humanitaire avec des
solutions concrètes avec des solutions
parce qu'il faut comprendre Raphaël piti
que les Gazaoui n'ont pas d'abri sous
les immeubles il y a les fameux tunnels
mais ils nont pas accès ça c'est le
ramasse et donc contrairement à ces
constructions en Israël avec des bunkers
des abris là il n'y a rien bien sûr
quand on est bombardé pour les les
habitants SR bien bien évidemment et
voyez ce qu'il en est pour ceux qui sont
partis du Nord et qui sont vers le sud
qui sont totalement à ciel ouvert
maintenant les conditions de vie sont
terribles ils sont dans les écoles ils
sont dans les mosquées ils sont dans des
dans les bâtiments dont ils ont pu
investir et cetera c'est la situation
qui est faite ils n'ont pas d'eau
potable ils n'ont pas d'eau potable
s'ils continuent à boire une eau qui
n'est pas potable on va avoir énormément
de diarrhées chronique de diarrées aigu
qui vont entraîner des décès par boiv
par l'eau salée qu'il boivent et cetera
et donc on est dans une situation
humanitaire je voudrais insister sur
cette situationl c'est vraiment un
pronostic vital d'une population qui est
engagée totalement et à très court terme
il est important que nous arrêtions cela
il est important et je le dis devant
tous ceux qui veulent bien nous écouter
et tous les responsables politiques qui
nous écoutent ne laissez pas se
perpétrer ce crime ne faites pas ce qui
s'est passé ce massacre de d'Israël ne
doit pas se survivre aussi en Palestine
et vous vous vous êtes sur liste
d'attente Raphaël piti pour y aller dans
cet enclave là dont certains de vos
collègues rêverient de sortir pour y
aller vous saveut dire quoi d'ailleurs
être sur liste d'attente et bien écoutez
c'est une liste d'attente qui a été
ouverte par palmed Europe Palm c'est une
association des médecins palestinien
européen qui existe et qui a bien
évidemment un très grand réseau à
l'intérieur de la S Jordanie comme de la
de la de la bande de Gaza bien
évidemment il est très très important
que nous soyons relativement nombreux en
tant que médecin pour y aller et donc
ils ont mis ils ont ouvert une
plateforme et ont demandé tous les
volontaires de bien vouloir s'y inscrire
je m'y suis inscrit bien évidemment
écoutez si vous y allez nous serions
ravis d'ailleurs de pouvoir communiquer
depuis là-bas avec vous vous nous
tiendrez au courant grand formateur à la
médecine de guerre et courageux ce qui
n'est pas voilà une une valeur si si
commune grand humaniste merci beaucoup
Raphaël piti c'est l'heure d' accueillir
nos affranchis pour leur parti prix vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite Fanny guinochet et ses infos
toutes fraîche pour France Info ce matin
mais aussi pour LCP du coup dans la même
journée sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale on y
vient dans quelques instants et Richard
Verly pour son billet européen bonsoir
bienvenue installez-vous on commence
avec Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour
à l'Assemblée nous a raconté ce soir par
Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir Stéphanie
bonsoir et l'histoire de l'article 3 de
la loi immigration qui électrise à
nouveau le groupe Renaissance c'est
celui vous le savez sur la
régularisation des sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension pour le gouvernement
le dilemme demeure faut-il modifier voir
sacrifier cet article pour obtenir les
voix des républicains et donc faire
passer son texte l'attentat d'aras a un
peu changé la donne ce weekend Gérald
Darmanin a dit et répété dans les médias
qu'il était prêt à discuter sans tabou
c'est un signal à droite la mesure
pourrait être prise par circulaire et
non plus figurer vraiment dans la loi
chez les député Renaissance aussi
l'attentat d'aras a changé un peu la
donne les voix de sont de plus en plus
fortes pour réclamer plus d'efficacité
plus de fermeté alors Myriam une autre
partie des députés du camp présidentiel
s'inquiète qu'on oublie le le volet
régularisation de ces travailleurs sans
papier et veulent qu'on marche sur les
deux jambes alors ce matin géralde
Darmanin est venu les rassurer il est
allé dans les trois réunions
hebdomadaires des trois groupes du camp
présidentiel pour garantir qu'il défend
cet article 3 et qu'il ne veut pas la
abandonné sauf que quelques heures plus
tard nos amis et confrères du Parisien
relancent le débat oui moins d'une heure
après la fin de la réunion entre Gérald
daranin et les députés Renaissance
patatra nos confrères du Parisien
annoncent qu'Élisabeth borne serait
prête à retirer l'article 3 elle
l'aurait confié lors d'un dîner avec
Bruno rotaillot le patron des sénateurs
les républicains c'est donc à peu près
l'inverse de ce que son ministre de
l'Intérieur a dit quelques heures avant
à ses propres troupes et évidemment ça
plait pas l'aile gauche en macronie très
remonté j'imagine par cet article oui
l'article a été publié juste avant la
séance de question gouvernement il y a
eu comme un moment de flottement une
montée de fièvre et un peu de stupeur
chez les élus renaissances favorable à
cet article 3 Sacha aoulier chef de fil
de l'elle gauche président de la
commission des lois vient finalement
s'exprimer devant les journalistes et il
affirme que matinou a démenti auprès de
lui tout retrait de l'article 3 il en
profite quand même pour mettre les
points sur les au cas où je crois pas
sur parole
brillot le ministre de l'Intérieur nous
a assuré que des mesures et qui les
soutenait et enfin ce sont les
parlementaires qui votent la loi on est
comme un coup de pression en fait du en
général les coups de pression je les
prends pas je les mets voilà s de lui un
peu plus clair un peu plus tard donc
Matignon affirme aux journalistes que la
première ministre non n'a pas changé
d'avis qu'elle est toujours favorable à
l'article 3 mais c'est que cette mesure
peut être améliorée bref le gouvernement
avance toujours sur un fil entre son
opposition à droite et sa propre
majorité le prochain rendez-vous ce sera
au Sénat début novembre pour vérifier
les rapports de force entre les
centristes et les républicains et voir
lors de ce premier round parlementaire
si l'article 3 disparaît du texte ou pas
ouais on verra ça c'est important pour
vous cette affaire de régularisation des
S papier dans le bâtiment la
restauration là où on manque de main d'
alors je suis tout à fait en au niveau
de la ville de mes je suis conseiller
municipal en charge justement de la
prise en charge des réfugiés et de leur
insertion h et je représente d'ailleurs
au niveau l'Association nationale des
villes et territoires accueillants je
suis vice-président de cette association
qui vise à ce que justement nos villes
soient accueillantes vis-à-vis de ce qui
se présentent alors je ne comprends pas
très bien nous sommes dans une situation
de tension dans notre pays il y a
beaucoup dans de de beaucoup
de de de de d'emplois qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas pris qui ne sont pas
pris et donc il est nécessaire pour le
fonctionnement de notre économie de
pouvoir avoir ces ces ces emplois soient
occupés par des gens qui ont la
compétence pour les prendre donc là ça
ne pose pas de problème il y a de
surcroix la circulaire Vals qui existe
qui fait que quelqu'un peut être
régularisé s'il remplit un certain
nombre de conditions qui s'il a du
travail s'il se sent il faut aller plus
loin et l'inscrire dans la loi pour vous
c'est une évidence oui mais d'un notre
côté nous sommes il y a toujours une
opposition à ce que nous ayons une
immigration puisqu'il s'agit de
migration économique dans ce cas-là qui
soit positive c'est-à-dire un peu comme
les Canadiens c'est-à-dire que nous
déterminons tous les ans le nombre de
postes que nous sommes capables de de
d'ouvrir a une migration positive de de
cette façon fameux cota or or ils sont
déjà là d'une certaine manière ces
gens-là cette immigration positive elle
est là alors parler de de de situation
sous tension et cetera il suit
simplement de dire ben écoutez nous
avons de régulariser cette situation de
fait de fait très bien merci ben j'avais
pas voilà forcément l'idée que ça vous
inspirerait autant on y va avec vous
Richard vous nous parlez ce soir de sur
la vanerleyenne plutôt dans la tourmente
he c'est vrai que cette présidente de la
Commission européenne multiplie les les
critiques à son encontre après sa
tournée en Israël son coup de fil à Joe
Biden est-ce qu'elle en fait trop est-ce
qu'elle est sorti de son rôle selon vous
alors d'abord poser cette question c'est
renvoyer la balle à Emmanuel Macron
parce qu'il ne faut jamais l'oublier
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui était allé la
chercher en 2019 et qui avait fait de
l'ancienne ministre de la défense
allemande sa nominée pour la Commission
européenne c'était un argument sans
faille elle venait de la CDU le grand
parti conservateur allemand elle
plaisait donc à la droite européenne qui
a remporté les élections de 2019 et et
bien sûr c'était une femme la première à
son poste alors en disant ça je voulais
m'écarter un peu de l'actualité parce
qu'effectivement cette actualité elle
est extrêmement dommageable aujourd'hui
pour Ursula van derleen alias VDL par
ses trois initiales d'abord elle est
beaucoup critiqué depuis sa visite à
Telavi vous l'avez dit le 13 octobre où
son discours proisraélien sans avoir
consulté les États-membres à à heuré la
deuxième chose c'est qu'elle avait
auparavant en Ukraine eu des positions
sur l'élargissement très favorable là
aussi semble-t-il sans trop consulter
les États-membres ses relations avec le
président du Conseil européen qui lui
représente les États-membres Charles
Michel sont détestables vous vous
souvenez il est vrai de cette fameuse
réunion en Turquie le siège qui manquait
en 2021 or les élections européennes
approchent du 6 au 9 juin 2024 de là à y
voir comme certains une stratégie
personnelle d'Ursula vleyen alors
expliquez-nous ça c'est c'est son c'est
son mandat ou son futur mandat qui
l'intéresse et bien écoutez je crois
qu'on peut se poser la question d'abord
il faut pas oublier aussi que lesun elle
est soupçonnée de conflit d'intérêts
dans l'affaire des vaccins Pfizer il y a
beaucoup de rumeurs les réseaux sociaux
en sont pleins donc c'est pas très
confortable si elle devait se
représenter à l'issue des élections
européennes devant les eurodéputés et
puis il y a un autre job il y a un job
où on parle de sécurité de relations
international un job qui est très
important pour les États-Unis allez je
vous le donne en 1 c'est quoi c'est
secrétaire général de l'OTAN elle a été
ancienne ministre de la Défense elle est
allemande elle n'est pas candidate mais
a-t-on besoin d'être candidate dès lors
que les États-Unis éventuellement
voudrai vous nommer donc donc la
question se pose il faut souvenir donc
qu'en 2019 elle avait été élue de
justesse la réalité c'est qu'on a quand
même l'impression qu'elle mène un agenda
personnel au sein d'une institution qui
doit représenter l'intérêt général de
tous les Européens les partis nationaux
populistes ne demandent que ça plus
vender lesun VDL brouille l'image de
l'Union européenne et bien plus les
adversaires de celle-ci engrange et
pique à VDL signé Richard Berly Merci à
VOUS Richard on va terminer avec vos vos
infos signé fan noet pour France Info et
aussi pour SCP allez sur le budget de la
Sécurité sociale on sait que le débat a
commencé dans l'hémicycle et sur la
contribution des retraites
complémentaires du privé pour équilibrer
le système général des retraites le
gouvernement a finalement renoncé oui il
ne piochera pas en tout cas pour l'heure
dans les caisses des retraites des
salariés du privé à JIR Arco alors c'est
vrai que tous les partenaires sociaux
étaient vent debout contre cette idée
c'était assez baroque mais il y avait
une alliance CGT medf le meddef qui
disait avec par la voix de Patrick
Martin son président que c'était une
très mauvaise que c'était une affaire de
principe qu'il fallait respecter le
paréarisme et puis Sophie Binet à la CGT
qui expliquait que c'était quand même la
double peine pour les salariés du privé
qui vont devoir travailler 2 ans de plus
avec la dernière réforme et qui par
ailleurs se faisait voler dans leur
caisse de retraite donc après des mois
de de discussion le gouvernement en tout
cas a décidé pour le moment de ne pas
piocher
via son projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale qu'il qu'il présentait
et il donne la chance au dialogue parce
que ellisabeth born dit qu'après des
années de de des mois de conflit contre
la réforme des retraites il est temps de
passer à un climat plus apaisé avec les
syndicats et le patron faut dire que le
gouvernement le sujet était devenu très
politique et le gouvernement commençait
un peu à pétocher de son opposition
exactement parce que le rassemblement
national de Marine Le Pen c'était par du
sujet et avait pris cause pour les
syndicats et le MDEF idem du côté de de
l'opposition à gauche notamment au PS et
puis aussi idem du côté des républicains
qui menaçaient de déposer une motion de
censure alors c'est vrai qu'éisabeth B
s'est dit que peut-être ça ne valait pas
le coup de
prendre tomber là-dessus sur une
histoire de retraite complémentaire ça
veut dire que c'est terminé ou le
gouvernement peut toujours redéposer un
amendement alors tout à l'heure quand on
écoutait euh Thomas kaznav le ministre
des comptes publicques il a bien précisé
pour l'heure parce que effectivement il
peut toujours au cours de la discussion
parlementaire déposer un amendement en
fait pour l'instant il dit aux
partenaires sociaux le gouvernement dit
aux partenaires sociaux je vous laisse
trouver une solution quand même ça
serait bien que de votre plein gré vous
participiez un petit peu au moins pour
équilibrer et venir abonder les petites
pensions du régime général d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure Marie Lise Léon a dit
qu'elle n'était de la CF FDT a dit
qu'elle n'était pas opposée qu'on
pouvait regarder ce sujet donc l'idée
c'est de dire aux partenaires sociaux de
leur mettre bien la pression pour leur
dire écoutez de vous-même essayer de
trouver un peu d'argent à nous donner
sans quoi sans quoi et bien on risque de
dégainer un amendement c'est une
histoire d'un milliard d'euros quandme à
la clé c'est rien trouver c'est pas rien
merci beaucoup on verra si les députés
trouve ce milliard il y a un 493 qui
arrive de toute façon Stéphanie des
piierr ou probablement dem jeudi h trop
de 493 tu le 493 raphaell piti chaîou
démocrae oui la démocratie
oui la démocratie oui la démocratie on
s'arrête là merci à vous merci Raphaël
piti d'être venu sur sur ce plateau et
merci à vous les affranchis pour vos
parties prix à très vite Stéphanie piier
pour un un nouveau Bourbon Express c'est
la fin de cette émission pour l'avoir
vous la revoir il y a la chaîne Youtube
d'cp bien sûr très belle soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain
[Musique]